[Music]
four stars are sounding off about Harvey
Weinstein but some are finding their
words backfiring Kevin Frazier joins us
now from our New York office with the
story Kevin Nancy as you can imagine the
Weinstein sex scandal is a sensitive
subject and now Mayim Bialik and James
Corden are under fire for how they
reacted it has been weird this week
though infinite watching all the ones do
alter if the women who watched him take
the ball it's weird watching Harvey
Weinstein in hot water
Gordon's jokes at a charity event
sparked backlash and this apology quote
to be clear sexual assault is no
laughing matter
I was not trying to make light of
Harvey's inexcusable behavior but to
shame him the abuser not his victims and
this morning the Big Bang theories Mayim
Bialik responded to critics who called
her recent Weinstein op-ed victim
blaming several actresses including
Gabrielle Union and Patricia Arquette
slam Bialik for her editorial where
among other things she wrote that she
self protects against unwanted advances
quote I dress modestly I don't act
flirtatiously with men as a policy
I am deeply deeply hurt if any woman in
particular who has been assaulted or man
thinks that in any way I was victim
blaming meanwhile actress Kate Winslet
is revealing why she snubbed Weinstein
in her 2009 Oscar speech thank you so
much my gosh Winslet won an Academy
Award for her role in the reader and
during her acceptance speech she thanked
19 people but not Harvey Weinstein whose
company financed and distributed the
movie Kate told the LA Times the
omission was quote absolutely deliberate
and although it had nothing to do with
sexual harassment Kate says the Mogul
exhibited disgraceful despicable
behavior and was bullying and nasty
during the making of the movie at least
38 women have now come forward claiming
Weinstein sexually harassed or assaulted
them singer Kelly Clarkson says the
scandal provides a teachable moment it's
a very important time I think right now
and
the history of our nation right now to
really have these conversations but not
only your girls but your boys and say
this is a night you treat a woman this
is how you treat a woman or with the
girls this is when you stand up for
yourself this is when you know whatever
those lessons are now Weinstein is
fighting back when it comes to his
company he was terminated last week but
a source tells us that he plans to
challenge his firing at tomorrow's board
meeting he will call in from Arizona
where he's getting treatment at a
private residence
[Music]
you